Ukraine says Russia has attacked
residential areas in Odessa Ukraine's
main grain Port has been repeatedly
targeted since Russia pulled out of the
Black Sea grain export deal last year
well we're now joined by Daniel Hawkins
who is in Moscow and uh Daniel in
regards to the Russian military plane
there have been statements from both
sides over the last 24 hours but there
are still far more questions than
answers right now aren't
there
indeed and of course facts being the key
word there as said by the Ukrainian
president and they're uh hard to come by
right now we understand of course the uh
Russian position was clear in the
immediate aftermath of this crash laying
the blame on Ukraine uh for what
happened we understand that the last
couple of hours the black boxes have
also been recovered by investigators
from the scene they could shed some more
light on what exactly happened yesterday
morning over the Skies of belgrod now uh
Kev has remained uh rather hesitant to
confirm or deny any involvement in this
crash though the picture has been
emerging over the last 24 hours building
up from Ukrainian media statements which
were published and some of which were
withdrawn by statements from the
president the general staff that Ukraine
may have had some sort of involvement in
this plane being shot down that will be
shown by the investigation of course if
that is established the question then is
how and why this could have happened and
that's where Ukraine blames Russia as we
heard there saying that Russia had
responsibility for the safety of these
prisoners and failed um in its
obligations to protect them now today
the Kremlin echoed president zelinsky's
words also calling for what it described
as an act of a crime by kiaf calling for
an international investigation um Sergey
lavro Russian for foreign ministers
calls yesterday for an emergency uh un
Security Council session were rejected
that is now due to take place uh
tomorrow and that's where we're likely
to see both sides uh present their
version of events and hopefully some
evidence uh from both sides as well uh
to back up their claims and counter
claims about exactly what happened and
Daniel the the Kremlin has since said
future prisoner swamps could actually be
in doubt what more do we know about all
of
this well just yesterday Russian
officials uh were in the EXT extremely
angry rhetoric said that any sort of
negotiation with KF was basically off
the table um after this crash and that
was partly echoed by the Kremlin
spokesperson ditri pesov this morning
who said that it's unclear um how this
incident is going to affect future
prisoner swaps subsequently Russia's
chair of the defense committee Andre kof
then said just in the last couple of
hours that um negotiations about
prisoner SWS would continue because
Russia simply had no other choice but to
talk to Ukraine uh to bring their
prisoners home um now pesov also said
these exchanges must happen in silence
alluding to the very complex process the
very lengthy negotiations that happen on
all levels to bring prisoners home
Russia of course took the unusual step
yesterday of releasing those prisoner
lists they said were on board that plane
presumably to back up their version of
events and there have been many prison
exchanges of course since the start of
the conflict pretty much the biggest one
around 200 soldiers from both both sides
sent home around the New Year indicating
a positive Dynamic um in these
negotiations but we understand thousands
remain on both sides and this incident
is going to have the families of those
PWS very worried about the future of
their loved ones indeed thanks so much
Daniel Daniel Hawkins for us there in
Moscow